Henry VIII logistics for the webinar
will be fairly straightforward it is 45
minutes in length followed by a
question-and-answer session we don't
expect you to have technical issues but
if you do related to sound or connection
the best solution is to log out and
reconnect we will be monitoring the chat
panel for questions so please post your
questions there and it will answer them
at the end as always we will upload all
of our Reece all of our webinar
resources to our studio comm and our
github as another reminder our next
webinar will be on Wednesday January
10th on the tidy eval by Lionel Henry
gary richie is our presenter for today
he is a software engineer working on the
r studio ide he's had several years of
experience at microphone you can reach
out to him on twitter at his handle
which is posted on the slide right now
i'm going to hand over the presentation
to gary thank you hi this is Gary
Ritchie as I said I'm a developer on the
Art Studio IDE 18 and and today I'm
going to be talking about the new
terminal pane in our Studio 1.1 this was
actually the first major or studio
feature I built since joining the
company and I'm excited to show it off
so as we said I'll be presenting for
about 45 minutes and then we'll have
around 15 minutes for Q&A and my plan is
to demonstrate from within our studio
itself rather than showing slides so let
me just get switched over to the death
there we go make sure it's there all
right okay so the ideal viewer of this
webinar I want to talk about my goals at
this webinar is someone who's already
got at least a basic understanding of
their operating systems command-line
interface so whether that's bash or
something like it which works on any of
the support at our studio platforms or
window specific shell like the command
prompt for PowerShell I'm going to
assume you're at least got a little bit
of familiarity with that if you don't
know what a terminal or command line is
then this webinar might pique your
interest in learning
I'm not really gonna be giving a
tutorial on that itself I'm gonna focus
more on the art studio of tournament
specifics than the general concepts so
let's get going so quick overview of
what I'm planning to talk about I will
briefly say what is a terminal I'm gonna
assume most people know that but I'll
give a quick talk about that and then
the fundamentals of the art studio
terminal you know the stuff you'd need
to know for the vast majority of what
you're gonna do in the terminal and then
a few features unique to our studio
around the terminal
if you don't metal dive into the
Microsoft Windows specific features and
options and quirks and then a little bit
on some advanced options and tips and if
we have time I might do even a brief
discussion of the art studio API and how
you can use that to programmatically
control the terminal with our that'll be
pretty brief but I think it's a fun
thing to show if you get a chance to
cool so here we are we are in our studio
this happens to be a server version but
things are pretty much the same whether
you're in our studio server or one of
the desktop version code you've probably
already seen if you're using our studio
there's this new terminal tab right next
to the console and you'd expect if you
click on it you get a terminal and again
here I'm on a server which means I'm
actually running on Linux and I'm using
the default bash shell so as you'd
expect you can go in there and run
commands again they're very specific to
what operating system you're on so I can
see some files or I could go into a
bigger list of files and again what you
would get as you can see you and your
support color in the terminal and scroll
back of course in this case I'm using
the mouse wheel you have a scrollbar as
well and our studio keeps about 1000
lines of scroll back and it'll start
throwing the weight stuff older than
that and that's really a performance
that if we keep too much it'll log down
so a thousand I believe it also what the
console keeps give or take so the most
common use of the terminal in our studio
most likely for the majority people
would be to
run get commands our studio has a really
nice yet feature built-in where you can
do the majority of things you need to do
get as a very powerful and complicated
beast and there are a few things that
you're probably going to need to do some
kinds of time we're dropping down to a
command line it's going to be more
efficient or let you do some things that
you simply can do with the user
interface so just as an example here I'm
gonna pull down something from github
that I'll be using later as we get to it
familiar with this don't worry about it
I'm gonna pull down the Aqua our studio
API package source code that very
quickly here there we go we've got it
sitting there and I'm actually gonna
load that up just so I can play with it
later so I'm gonna open the project Andy
so now we've got the project loaded and
through that another thing the terminal
can do the backend we can run full
screen programs and by that I mean
things like text editors so run them run
Emacs those sorts of things and you
might wonder well why would you do that
you're already in an IDE that has a
really nice user friendly editor and
that's that's fair if you're connecting
to a remote server though it's not so
you might be SSH into another server
from the terminal maybe to run some sort
of batch jobs or even administer that
you know another server then you may
have need to run an editor in there and
that at least gives you that capability
another one that I like to show that I
think was in a some other demo I was age
top is a handy little utility that lets
you see your running processes and
variety of detailed information about
them and do you know kill them and
things like that so examples of the
sorts of things you could run in the art
studio terminal so that's kind of fun
another thing you can of course you can
use you know Fieros or other shortcuts
to see your command history you can use
the tab key to get completion and all of
this
is part of your shell so this isn't
implemented by our studio itself these
are things don't into in this case batch
or whatever shall you're using so our
studio is just showing you the shell
running it and it it exposes its own
implementation that includes configuring
it so this is run as a login shell so
you can go ahead at the standard config
files that your particular shell uses to
customize you know your prompt and your
colors and whatever else you might want
to do and again this assumes you're
familiar with these things and I've
already probably tinkered with them a
little um other basics you know as I
said you can scroll and of course you
can select with the mouse you can do you
know you can do copy and paste I let's
bring up a bring up the text file and
paste in there to show that happening so
you know the basics that you would
expect another really useful thing to be
aware of is ctrl L so this is a shortcut
that if you hit ctrl alt order in the
terminal it clears the entire terminal
including the scroll back buffer and
this is exactly like what the console
but if you're in the console if you hit
ctrl well where's the console so we just
made it so that you're in the terminal
that same key will will clear the
terminal so just if you have muscle
memory on that that's a good way to do
it you can also use this little broom
icon that's sort of hiding up in the
corner here if you're more click tune
for clicking and there's also a command
on this drop-down menu to clear the
buffer so there's a variety of ways to
do things to try and make them easier to
discover and that shows the we do have
this drop-down menu in the terminal pain
with with a variety of commands and
probably the most interesting one is new
terminal so to click on that you'll see
we now have terminal 2 and otherwise
looks the same but this is this is a
truly independent terminal at this point
it's completely separate from the other
one and we can navigate we can create a
third one and we can navigate between
them in a variety of ways so we can use
these arrows that light up when you have
you can really see here is the the
terminal I'm changing and you go to the
drop-down menu there's also a list of
the terminal as you've created and
there's also keyboard shortcuts
try to make it so you can discover the
shortcuts that you might find useful for
you and like I said so if we make this
terminal pause so sleep for a hundred
seconds for this one sitting here doing
nothing and switch over this one is
still fully functional it's so alive so
it lets you you know you have multiple
jobs you need to do some of you know
they're taking longer or requires some
setup work then provided a way to to
configure that again for many people
probably a single terminal that's is
gonna do the trick but having that
capability is really nice well I've got
it well I've got this one sleeping
you'll notice that it says busy yeah
it's busy to the name and it also adds a
little stop sign over here which to
click on it sends interrupts and it
kills that program it's good to know you
know there's some implications to a
terminal being busy so I'll sleep this
one again and this is a little tricky to
explain but the terminal is running as a
child of your our session so when you
run our studio it starts in our session
and that's where all your work is
happening your your environment your
workspace you're running the terminal in
our studio is actually a child of that
and the implication of that is if you do
anything in our studio that needs to
kill off that session and restart it it
also has to kill off the terminals and
restart them and that's important to
know it's not very intuitive there's
some reasons why but it's done that way
I will get into those but for certain
types of workflows it's important to be
aware of that so if you're running
things in the terminal that are taking a
while you know maybe you've got a text
editor open and haven't saved your work
before you're running some sort of batch
job and you're doing things that want to
restart the our session let's try you
know so I've loaded a project a package
project earlier art studio API and
install and restart to think in the
earlier versions this build and restart
that actually needs to restart our so if
I click on that it will warn me that the
terminal is busy and if you continue
it's going to kill things and gives you
a chance to interrupt that the same is
true if I try to quit our studio
altogether or you know in the other
operation that needs to do that so
depending on what you do at the terminal
and what sort of work
our studio you may never care about that
or it could be extremely irritating I'll
talk a little bit later on about some
ways you can mitigate that so just
wanted to point that out because very
non-intuitive but that's just the way it
is okay so that's you know in a nutshell
that is really the basic terminal
features that you're gonna need the
majority of the time you know you can
start up terminals one or more run
commands you can copy/paste you know in
or out of the terminal scroll around
clear the screen and that sort of thing
so you know again that's pretty much
what you would expect other the full
feature terminal talking about earlier
versions of our studio just as an aside
really so in the past there was in our
studio one bow and earlier there was its
tool shell command and it's still there
and what that command did in the past
was if you were on a desktop version of
our studio sort of our studio on the Mac
or Linux or Windows the shell command
would just launch your operating systems
terminal program so a separate program
you know it's really there is
convenience you know bring up the
command prompt and windows or terminal
app on the Mac or whatever your Linux
terminal program was and on the desktop
versions of our studio one one it still
does that you just left it there if
you're used to that in your workflow you
know you have muscle memory on that and
that's how you like to work then we just
left it alone on our studio server which
is what this happens to be this used to
bring up a little modal window which
means it would pop up in our studio and
block everything out so you couldn't do
anything else well this was up it had
very limited capabilities it was good
enough to run maybe a gif command or
some other basic good do anything else
both was going you wouldn't want to run
a long job in it or I don't think you
could do most thing so in the server
product one one and above all we've done
is we've changed that we left it there
now it just pops you over to the
terminal pane just so if you're used to
going to that at least it still takes
you somewhere useful so there we go
people talk about so that's basic
terminal stuff now we'll talk a little
some our studio specific twists and
things were able to do with our studio
by building the terminal and probably
the most interesting one is this very
simple but powerful thing of sending
text from the text editor straight to
the terminal so they have let's just put
in some very basic terminal commands to
be a bash program of course I'll just
use the echo command which you know just
spits out its type what we can do here
it's very similar to what you would do
if you're editing our source code you
can hit control enter and that's and the
current line of our code down to the
console well here you can do control alt
enter and it sends the current line of
the editor to you from terminal and
moves the first year down the line so we
run echo hello
I hit alt ctrl alt enter in it and it
bounced that into the terminal shows the
result do it again it will move down
again and again so this can be very
handy if you're writing bash scripts it
gives you a nice basic you know ability
to build up a script and try out parts
of it from up here ok nothing you
couldn't do with copy/paste and a
separate terminal or the pain but it's
it's a it's a nice little enhancement to
your workflow if that's if that's when
you need the actual command for that if
you need if you like to find things like
menus is under code send the terminal
and again it's a good way to go discover
the shortcuts if you're not not familiar
with them and one team shortcuts so
that's that's very powerful another
thing we've shown off I believe is you
know it's not specific to bash say
anything so if you run be around a
Python command line interpreter down
here and put in some Python I'm not a
Python expert so I'll just do this
really advanced Python code right here
and do control all the enter same thing
it'll set it stick it down there and
pass it to the interpreter and you can
do that with anything I mean you could
run you could run command line are down
here so you should do this but you could
do that and now we have our going and
you could have our code up here and use
control over enter and send it to here
and this just as another aside if you
run are in the terminal inside our
studio it's a complete
a separate session it's not somehow
connected to the our session that you're
seeing everywhere else so you know that
might even be useful on occasion but
just be aware that you run are in the
terminal it's completely independent
from the are that the rest of our studio
is using itself but there's nothing that
says you can't do it so that's that
another thing that our studio does
that's a little unusual or you know
handy so we have our multiple terminals
open here and let's just put some stuff
in them so we can recognize them so we
have Terminal one this one we've already
got some our stuff that we've done
Terminal three we did some sleeping so
these buffers actually get saved if you
do restart ours
now when you restart our or refresh your
web browser all of that goes away and
typically in a terminal program you you
lose all of that but our studio actually
keeps them all so if I do install and
restart so you see the restarting our so
that's not actually behind the scenes
killed those terminals but it remembers
the terminal buffers and the set of
terminals you have and that can be
useful if you're building up a set of
terminals for very specific things and
have generated output in there you don't
want to lose our studio tries really
hard even though it's killing the
terminals sometimes to keep the context
you had in there so so that's not
necessarily obvious it just kind of
works most of the time you won't even
notice that but it's it's a powerful
feature that is their tool okay so like
I said earlier Windows has some unique
twist everything we've seen here is very
UNIX II Mac Linux they're basically the
same in our studio server the Windows
version of our studio has a few other
works and tricks and I'm going to switch
over to the bat alright alright so here
we have our studio on Windows and I
think the font that's big enough to see
everything and the terminal feature is
very operating system specific we try
hard with our studio to make it as
uniform
can across the different operating
systems and I think that's one of the
cool features of it as you can you know
use it on these different environments
and for the most part it works the same
way the terminal by definition is a very
operating system specific thing so there
had to be a few specific operating
system tweaks here so as you can see if
we go to the terminal right now what we
get on Windows initially is the good old
you know essentially DOS prompt if
you're old enough to remember what a
Doc's prompt is so you get your your
very exciting you know try on processor
where you can do things like that
probably the least useful command prompt
these days and on Windows if we go to
tools world--all options and terminal
what we get is this drop-down where we
can see our choices and there's actually
quite a few on Windows so the command
prompt which is what we have there's a
32-bit and 64-bit that's generally not
going to be useful to you to know the
difference and if you have 64-bit
available that's probably what you want
so that as soon as you're running 64-bit
Windows which most people are leasing on
newer systems now there's very obscure
cases where you might actually select
32-bit on purpose but those are very
very rare but I put it in there just so
you could have those cases then I'm
going to switch the PowerShell and
clicked ok now that doesn't change the
current terminal
so whatever once you create a terminal
like Terminal one in this case it
remembers what type of Shou it had and
switching the option doesn't change that
and just as a little demo let's rename
this terminal I didn't show this earlier
so we can say well this one is running
the command prompt this is just a handy
way if you are setting up some terminals
new specific things you give them name
so you can remember what they were
we got that one and then I changed so
that the next terminal will actually be
PowerShell and if there's PowerShell and
you can tell because the text is yellow
and harder to see because PowerShell
really likes a dark background
so actually I'm going to switch this
over to show our darker themes this one
that it's actually contributed by a user
as well
there's a little more visible and now
it's full-blown so I can do my
tab-completion and you know give
PowerShell and that's going on so that's
fun let's just continue this little semi
neurotic behavior of mine and call this
PowerShell and they need to show you the
options but those are the two that are
sort of built into Windows so those will
always be there you always have command
prompt and PowerShell although I think
there are cases where PowerShell is also
not installed those are generally the
standard Windows terminal IDs at this
point the other two ones that are
optional so git bash is a package it's
not by Microsoft but if the windows
package that you've probably heard of
the keys or studio on Windows and that's
what our studio likes to use for its git
integration you have it installed then
it becomes an option for the terminal as
well so we'll select that one will do a
new terminal there and there we go and
this is much more UNIX II of course so
we've got that up and running and can't
help myself to do this and so now we've
got our three terminals running
different types of terminals and we will
yes indeed go do the last one and the
other one is - windows subsystem for
linux and this is a Microsoft thing so
you need Windows 10 64 bit and then you
can install this package for Microsoft
that gives you this windows subsystem
for Linux which I believe Microsoft Word
thumb with canonical to bring in full
fledge Linux subsystem improve Microsoft
era so let's do that one and hold for
bathroom and there we go so now we've
got we've got that so all right so now
we've got four different types of shells
running and you're not likely to do this
very often but I just want to show that
these are actually very independent can
exist at the same time I'm trying to
think of some other good demos within
these so that one I showed earlier this
little process viewer each top okay it's
not installed and because we're in a
real term
and I know the root password I can go do
things like this all right all the
package don't worry if this is absolute
garbage we give to you that basically at
the terminal I installed another
terminal base program and now I can run
it in there so very handy and this is
potentially very handy if you're in our
studio a server administrator let's use
from within our studio bounce over to
the server because when you're in our
studio server and you're running the
terminal those terminal shells are
running on the server not on your local
computer and so your which is the way
you wanted it's running under your
security context whatever you logged in
to our studio server with it's what your
terminal is running under and you know
if you have data on the server in that
that's what you get at it if you're
running an art studio desktop version
then of course when you run the terminal
you're running it locally so just
thought I should mention that so there
we go
a couple of other windows works you know
so these are kind of this is like stuff
you can do in Windows that's not really
on the other platforms are these
different terminal types let's see we've
got that we've got some stuff in each
one of these now I showed earlier that
when you do certain environments that
reload everything we reload the contents
of the terminals even though we've
killed them you didn't try to bring it
back there's some limitations on Windows
so if you're running git bash or the wsl
windows service subsystem for linux bash
we actually can reload those buffers so
let's this case I'll refresh the browser
that's another way to show it off I'm
not sure also there we go terminal is
eating only keyboard shortcut so oh I'm
on Windows never mind I'll do it here I
can actually do a reload right here I
was thinking I was in a web browser but
I actually did a little trip to refresh
the
sir I've actually killed off my
WebSocket but what we find there is the
command prompt can't reload its text and
same as PowerShell currently it did
that's interesting
git bash can and bash can so in general
there were some interesting stuff there
I'll have to play that general on
Windows if you're doing things that are
causing the terminals to be killed and
reloaded
we can't reload the command prompt text
and the powershell text but we can
reload get bash & bash and that's this
dude is an obscure system differences
and hope to maybe improve that in the
future
so let's kill that off back to here
unlike the that's really it windows it's
the different terminal types and some
minor differences on actually there is
one more windows thing i should show a
lock just as there could be important
let's go back to our new terminal so I
strode earlier that our studio can tell
if your terminal is busy and warned you
before you kill it on Windows there are
some limitations there so here I am in
the git bash terminal and I ran a sleep
command which is you know is he doing
nothing on Mac and Linux and server it
would have said the terminal one is now
busy and shows a little stop sign on
Windows unfortunately when you're in
bash or get bash we can't detect that
you're busy and so it won't warn you if
you go to try and kill that it will just
kill it if you're running stuff in the
command prompt for PowerShell because
those are more standard windows things
we actually can tell if they're busy and
warn you so it's a little inconsistent
there something to be aware of if you
happen to run into that sort of thing
alright that's enough on Windows for now
let's go switch back to our server back
to our our studio server that we were
doing if the game is running in chrome
in this case so now let's dig in a
little bit on some of the more
interesting options
some quirks as well so the terminal
command if we go to the Tools menu
there's this new terminal submenu and
this list of commands is almost
identical to what you get on the
terminal drop-down there's a few
differences to go here couple of
differences are there's also this move
focus to terminal command and that's a
good one to know at least in terms of
learning the shortcut the difference
between these two is new terminal let's
say we've switched a console and maybe
we're up here in the text editor
we do new terminal that will always
switch to the terminal tabbing as you
would expect create a new terminal so
you probably don't want to use that
command as your way to switch back to
the terminal tab because every time you
do it you're gonna get another terminal
instance and before you know that's
going to be out of control so what you
really want to use in that case this is
the move focus to terminal and that's a
good shortcut to learn as your way to
you know if you're a shortcut the kind
of person that's your way to get back to
the terminal without spawning you know
that ridiculous number of terminals
which one to show that is and you can
actually bind that into the View menu as
well view the focused of terminal so any
command to know if you're a terminal
user back under this menu the only other
real difference here is there is the
same terminal Diagnostics now this is
pretty obscure and you're not likely to
ever use this unless you're working with
you know our studio support or in New
York to do community forums and having
trouble with your terminal this is
generally some good information to share
if you're getting some troubleshooting
help and that's pretty much than you
would do that by bringing this up and
copy pasting this text you can also if
you click a pen buffer this isn't a very
interesting example would be get some
more stuff in here a big list of stuff
in the terminal you are terminal
Diagnostics we click the pen buffer it
does like I said it will actually this
isn't a very long one which is good it
actually puts the texture of your buffer
including these hidden escape sequences
that's what actually creates the colors
into here
and if that's relevant to your case and
this is the same thing without those the
safety include that you know obviously
want to make sure you're not including
anything in here that's you know you
don't want to share and that's why I
made it require an extra step because
you may not want to share what's in your
terminal or you may want to be aware
that you should edit some stuff out but
and that's a fairly rarely used option
but it's very handy if you're if you're
having problems it helps us understand a
little more what might be going wrong
that's really it for this menu this is
really here oh there is one more purpose
for this menu so if you're in the
terminal pane you'll notice you can
close your current terminal with this
little X up in the upper right hand
corner a little grayed out depending on
your colors deep so clicking that closes
the current terminal if the terminal is
busy as you would expect it will word
you I could change to a stop sign so
can't even use it that way so there's
that there's also on the terminal menu a
closed terminal that gets rid of the
current one and obviously if you're
eternal you can also just type exit that
kills off that one and it goes away so
variety of ways to kill the current one
if you click the X up on the tab itself
that kills all the terminals underneath
and just do this time will be sweet my
standard way of making the terminal busy
with an apple now if I try to click that
it will warn me because it doesn't want
to kill things without agreeing to it
let's kill that off close that it closes
all the tabs and the terminal tab goes
away now you're back to what you would
have seen more in our studio 1.0 if you
didn't have anything else open down here
so if you're not interested in the
terminal it's not something you're ever
going to use or you know it's just
generally ruining your day you can click
on that and the terminal goes away and
it remembers that so the next time you
run our studio on this on this system
you won't get the terminal tab so that
can be great I just wanted to go away to
close that accidentally or you discover
along the way oh that might be useful
it's important to know how to get it
back and to do that you can use these
same commands I was just showing so I
could use a view move focus to terminal
and
create the terminal tab and if there are
no children holes in which was the case
that will create the first terminal but
if you use that one again then it will
just bring up the existing line won't
create a never-ending series of
terminals so that's one way you can also
bring back the tab so if I close the tab
same thing will happen with the new
terminal bring it forward to create a
terminal so that's how you get it back
if you happen to close the whole thing
where where those things are cool
so a few more things on options so we
saw this on Windows a little bit so if
we go tools global options terminal so
this is a little different on Mac and
Linux and server than it was on Windows
there's a few more things here they're
all fairly obscure but I think the
important one to look at is the terminal
option so unlike Windows where we had
this big list of sort of cam choices
command prompt PowerShell get bashed and
so on here we have bash which is the
built-in thing we support and just some
people look care that actually runs when
you run that when you're running user
bin and minus L so that's relevant to
some people they want to know what how
do I configure that and so it is running
it as a login shell - Ethan it's finding
it using this so they're having cases
where people have installed their own
versions of bash especially on the Mac
and they're finding that we're still
picking up an older version of bash and
this should be enough for you to figure
out why why is that so I try to mention
that it's a super specific thing so back
to here so that if you want to run a
different show you go to custom and now
you're responsible for finding the full
path to it and any options you want to
use so I need to show an example of
doing that so one popular one is the EU
dead shell I'm Canadian so for me it's
the dead shell but I recognize that
there may be an American on here
oh and I've already got it installed so
that tool so if I go I'm actually glad
to just ran it like a witch said shout
this will give me the path to it so now
I can grab that copy it go to my options
terminal again this isn't something
you'd do very often so it is a little
cumbersome all right let's put out in
there I'm not gonna bother with any
options for now and now if I bring up a
new terminal it is indeed gonna run this
shelf which the first time through does
some stuff let's just do that now I knew
Shou and any new terminals I bring up
will we'll run that one so that's how
you do custom terminal types on
everything but windows so let me go back
and reset that back and then some of
these other choices just fairly briefly
these first two local terminal echo and
connect with WebSockets those are very
much around performance of the terminal
you'll generally want to leave these on
except if you're having trouble getting
the terminal to work if you if it just
won't connect at all or it's taking a
long time to connect especially on the
server our studio server you can try
part of the first advice will give you
this little try turning these two off
and try fading a new term I'll see if it
works there and if that does then try
turning one on you got it you want to
ideally have these on the terminal will
have its better performance when these
are on but you may run into cases where
it can't work with these WebSockets
particularly is important for
performance especially on a server so
you really want to try and make that
work and that might require changes to
your systems proxy that can get fairly
involved but that's ideally gonna be
left on it will work without WebSockets
but it is much more sluggish local
terminal echo is little more obscure
that one if there's some symptoms of
problems with that if your backspacing
in your command prompt and it won't
erase some characters that's the most
common problem and they imply that your
terminal shower configurations isn't
quite compatible with this turnout but
again probably get that information
through support conversation or the
community forums the other two I'll just
leave those alone this one can be
interesting so process termination so
right now the default is if you're
exiting a terminal
and there's something running it'll
always warn you that's the default you
can tell it to never warn you if you
don't care you never do anything in the
terminal that you don't find if it gets
killed and you can set it to never in
our studio will just kill terminals so
any any complaints whatsoever from our
studio and the third one is is the fun
one I won't have time to get into this
in much detail but this can be helpful
that you want to have complicated things
running but you also need to restart the
art section so I mentioned that earlier
so by default it lists these two
programs and if one of these is running
and is keeping the terminal busy it
won't warn you I don't have time to
explain these in much detail there's
lots of stuff out there but there are
screen multiplexers there the probably
the two most common so I'm going to turn
that on what that lets me do here that
terminal get rid of some journals clear
this one okay but that lets me do is run
this program T MUX and within that I can
do all sorts of fun things like pretty
multiple panes in various directions and
run different terminals there that one
is pretty tiny and this kind of runs
under its own little separate server and
it will stay alive these may be too
small to really let me run a little
editor here I'll go to this other one
run run this other program I showed now
these is running keeping busy oh it
shouldn't actually be saying good me so
I think I need to restart all right
killed off terminating one quark was the
terminal options and even though I wrote
this I'm still not getting a quick clear
it is some of the options take effect
immediately
some of them require a restart so that's
something I hope to clear up in the
future so that it's never quite so
mysterious create a new one then either
the run team ups and it's not busy there
we go
let me just run them and run second
program okay so now I've got
team-ups so they should have in the past
those would have been keeping our
Studios Terminal busy but now because I
told her to ignore Tmax it doesn't think
the terminal is busy and I can do things
like this install and restart without
complaining so in this configuration
it's a little annoying because you'd
still have to go here and reattach but
they're still there so that's that sort
of the brute force way of doing it this
will let you set up things and run
multiple jobs within this other program
that won't be killed when our studio
restarts and you probably would end up
just using one terminal then let team ox
or screen which is the other program
that does this sort of thing handle it
for you and will very quickly show this
back to the options there's this link at
the bottom using the art studio terminal
and that'll take you to a fairly lengthy
help article and in there I mentioned
and a little more detailed way you
configure a custom terminal such that it
automatically reattaches to team X when
it starts and can even be project
specific and things like that so if
you're if that sort of thing is
important to your workflow you can
actually configure it to them and you
run the terminal way just sort of
automatically connects to these programs
and so you can restart our studio to
your heart's content and it will still
have your program so that's a pretty
advanced thing but I thought I should
mention that all right so get out of
this giant mess with terminal stuff
there we go alright I think that's
enough in terms of the overall terminal
stuff I've thrown a lot out there at you
mind isn't swimming already then let's
add one more thing the programmability
and this is more fun I won't have time
to get to any level of detail but so the
other studio API is the package and it's
up on cran and stuff that lets you
control parts of our studio from our
code it's often used to help write
add-ins and sort of some more advanced
usages and as part of the terminal I
created some api's to let you control
the terminal so that's a little and I've
got the art studio package loaded
because I actually built it here just to
get it up there and so the
a series of api's they all start with
the word terminal and there's quite a
few of it but what it lets you do or
things like well it's the terminal list
okay that means there are currently no
terminals let's create a terminal read
in there if you've now created a
terminal from our and just run something
there back at the console terminal Crais
returns this little ID that's the unique
idea of the terminal we created each one
you create needs its own little ID and
to a mental list we'll return the list
of terminals so now I can do something
fun like show me the terminal buffer in
this case the single terminal and it
actually gives you the contents in the
console or in our variable of what was
over here in the terminal and you can
also use these commands to kill terminal
send text to terminals run a command and
just have an exit but keep the text in
there so I have to leave it to you to
find out if that's useful to you or if
that is got some potential to help
ascertain you know more advanced
workflows so there we go I think I'm
going to looks like oh wow I'm sort of
on time how did that happen
I think I'm going to wrap up there throw
in a lot of self stuff out and I think
we're ready to move on to some questions
so let's have a look at some questions
here okay all right so I see a question
here on is the terminal tab available in
which version in their version was 1.0
0.15 3 so the terminal tab was added for
version 1.1 which came out this past
fall
so yeah you would need to be running 1.1
or or newer to get the terminal tab that
was one of the big new features then in
1.1 ok that another question what
advantage is there to using terminal
within our studio instead of using
terminal directly from the oh that's not
the great question it depends it really
is a matter of what you're comfortable
with or
what is the most efficient for you so
you know yeah like I say that's really
not a whole lot you can do with the
terminal built into our studio that you
can't do with the native operating
system terminal but depending on how you
like to work if you like to have one big
window
you know our studio filling the screen
and try to stay in there and work and
the ability to pop down to the terminal
within our studio and run a command and
grab the text might work better for you
then switching over to switching context
to another terminal program all together
or not it really depends on how you like
to work or if you want to use the
ability to like I showed you know send
text from the text editor straight to a
terminal with one shortcut versus and
copy paste that might be helpful to you
it's really powerful if you're running
in our studio server which you know if
you're on a desktop Mac version that's
not relevant but if your honors to the
server then your our session and all of
your stuff is running somewhere else and
the ability to run the terminal within
our studio means you're automatically
connected to that server and from
commands there whereas you might
otherwise need to you know get some sort
of setup with your administrator to
remote Shaolin to that which may or may
not be possible so it can be real
advantage especially on our studio
server so that's that's my answer to
that one and then secure are there any
security concerns about using the
terminal in our studio so that's an
interesting one I would say yes in
general just because you know a terminal
is a very powerful tool you can you know
very easily with one command wipe out a
lot of your own work so much a security
concern but it's just a general concern
so you want to know what you're doing at
a terminal in an opportunity to a server
environment the terminal does like I
said lets you operate stuff on the
server but it's under the same security
context as your our studio session so
when you log into our studio servers you
provided credentials it's running as
that user so you really can't do
anything there that you couldn't already
do because our itself let you run
command now
yeah but granted you're in a terminal
you're probably you can experiment more
quickly and find more fun commands to
run but from a pure security
one of you having the terminal running
there doesn't actually give you any more
capability to to do evil than you
already have by running our codes in
more controlled environments there is an
option in our studio server crow to turn
off the terminal feature again that
doesn't prevent our codes from doing
things on that server but at least it
takes it out of your face so so yeah
it's it's it's a powerful tool but it
doesn't technically cause any more
problems than what you already could do
just from our code all right
can we add other terminals on Windows
such as a cig win - another good
question
not currently I mean you can go right
now you can go within a command prompt
and run these other ones and have them
show up sometimes I did actually at one
point have cygwin running within it but
it's not currently a choice you can't
add custom terminals on Windows
currently so you right now you have that
set of choices so your best you could do
is run a command prompt and within that
start up your other batch that you like
to use which is a little cumbersome so
you know I think if cygwin or another
one is important I would open an issue
up on github and then we kind of look at
you know what kind of feedback we're
getting on those to decide if it's
something we should consider adding all
right Willie editor do syntax
highlighting for shell scripts not I
don't recall I know you can create a
file and have it be of the batch type I
don't recall let me just try the trader
Gary you got SH file and so it's not a
shell I don't I don't looks like there's
a little bit so I'm not super actually
super familiar with that yeah it looks
like there is I don't yeah yes that was
good I didn't actually try that but yes
if your script is open and it's type is
set to shell which I believe currently
requires it only happens if you're not
SH as far as I'm aware so there might be
some limitations if you're writing other
types of shell scripts it looks like for
generic not at Sage files it does indeed
happily some level of highlighting so so
that's cool all right okay okay that's
the it's another question
I saw one on the terminal buffer
terminal if someone said so I had shown
that bit of the API right at the end
very quickly with the terminal our
studio ap guys and someone wrote
terminal buffer parentheses terminal
list does not work on my computer and
yes that won't work unless you've
installed the our studio API package and
the most recent version of that and I
delete and loaded app YouTube into
context but if that's in there and
University one thing one that should be
working so if you're still not getting
that to go go ahead and ping me on
Twitter and all I'll see if we can
figure out what's going on there okay
let's see what other questions are fun
to look at so I know there's another one
asking about a custom shell under
windows like the hamilton sea shell
again same answer right now no not
directly and if it's important I would
say open an issue on github under
github.com slash our studio slash our
studio issues and weird be happy to look
at that when sending commands to
terminal from our can I get the result
back in our so if that's reference to
the API yes you can again I think that
referring to the art studio API yes you
can you can send not in one operation
you can send the command to the terminal
when I play to this what I'll used to do
is include bit of a delay you can
actually send a command and then ask the
terminal if it's still busy so if you
want to send a command that does a lot
of stuff it's gonna take a while before
it has the output for you could you
could write a little loop that checks
the terminal see if it's still busy and
once it's no longer busy you can then
query what's in the terminal buffer and
then parse that so that's you know
that's a bit finicky and that you'd have
to handle whatever the output format is
there isn't a direct right now run this
and give it to you there's always the
separate operation so that's the best I
can say on that there's our studio
terminal support everything as an
operating system terminals can interpret
that question a few ways in general yes
so anything you could do in your
operating system terminal that you have
permissions to do based on your user
account then yes you should be able to
do that in your studio terminal that's
that's the general answer you might find
some things that don't work as well as
and you know the operating studio
operating system terminal might you know
if you need 10,000 lines of scroll back
you might have better luck in the
operating system terminal let's see okay
question about I've been using the new
terminal feature and I've noticed that
if I open a terminal from within Server
Pro move to another tab or another
program for a while return to terminal
the terminal is closed and no longer
interactive further plans for this to be
remedy yes yes actually just last week
sort of narrowed in on this and we
understand the problem and it should be
a fixed in in the first major patch to
our studio 1.1 so yeah that's that has
definitely been a problem in server in
certain scenarios and it's actually
related to web sockets which I showed
earlier so if that's if that's causing
you made from grief right now you could
actually temporarily work around it by
turning off web sockets and the terminal
options unfortunate that will make your
terminal pretty sluggish but it should
not have this problem and once we go to
fix I'll you could turn that back on so
that's a good little workaround in the
meantime big area tank we've got time
for one more question okay
okay someone's stuck in traffic
yeah all right let me see good question
so what would be the most useful
how do you manage differences within
terminals with file system paths visa
vos platforms
yeah that's very much something you have
to deal with so the terminal you know
it's kind of its kind of a blank
rectangle that runs code that's part of
the operating system inside of it and so
once you're inside that rectangle it's
really your responsibility to you know
know what your commands to run and how
to deal with the results we don't do
anything specifically in the terminal to
try and you know hi the differences
between platforms that's just it's much
more of the terminal is much more of a
system level feature it's not really a
date of science feature our feature even
really an arch didn't feature it's just
a window into something that's part of
your operating system so it's a much
more generic feature than most our
studio features in that sense and very
operating systems because we think
that's the best I could say on that all
right
well I think that's I think that's where
I'm gonna leave it thank you very much I
hope hope I didn't blab on too much and
that you got some useful information
about it I would recommend like I said
before if you'd rather read some of this
go to global options in in the terminal
go to the global options terminal pane
and at the bottom of that there is a
link to use the arc to do terminal that
takes you to a pretty long help article
that covers a lot of the same
information where you don't have to
listen to me you can just read what I
wrote in the steps up thank you well
thank you so much Gary uses that you
found that helpful I did see two
questions related to more logistical
issues one is this webinar going to be
recorded yes we will post it online and
on get within 48 hours and then there
was another question related to the
registration for our next webinar the
tidy eval look for community follow-up
communication with a registration link
after this webinar ends and then also
check back on our webinars site page
within the next couple of days and
you'll be able to register there in
addition to that just as a reminder here
are our open source and
products you can download our pro
products 45-day evals of them without
restrictions on our website so be sure
to check them out of Vietnam so already
and we encourage you to stay in touch we
are active on a whole bunch of online
platforms they've recently uploaded most
of our webinars to YouTube we think that
our last webinar on the our Studio IDE
by Jonathan McPherson pairs nicely with
this content so you can check that out
on git and on our website so if you have
not checked out that webinar we
encourage you to do that and then if you
reach out to us on any of these other
platforms we will try our best to get
back to you thank you guys again for
attending we hope to hear from you and
we hope that this webinar was helpful
Thanks